what are we doing digging up Mean Girls
a Beloved movie from my childhood that
is fine as is and making a Shameless
sequel what is the point except that is
not what is happening at all and I think
I'm going slightly insane at this
situation so here let me catch you up
this upcoming Mean Girls movie is not a
remake of the popular 2004 movie
starring Lindsay Lohan but rather is an
adaptation of the critically beloved
Mean Girls Broadway musical no Shameless
remakes here it's a musical now with
that out of the way what is going on
with this movie's marketing why are they
so desperate to hide that fact it
boggles my mind that the folks in charge
of that would come to this decision like
do they not understand how people will
just immediately write it off as a
Shameless remake cash grab otherwise not
to mention people going to the showings
expecting a regular remake movie and
then suddenly people start singing my
brain is breaking trying to make sense
of this please someone out there help it
make sense